driven by hunger refugees queue for
lunch
at the umrakuba camp the food is
prepared and served by relief groups
with the help of refugees
but the choices are limited
these people have been living on lentil
soup with a portion of sorghum porridge
for 20 days
this type of food doesn't necessarily
suit everyone
we have only this type of food that you
see here i had it for 14 days
now people are throwing it away they
don't want it anymore
the world food programme is the main
provider of aid relief in the camps
it says every registered refugee gets
enough to eat
this is the main food store of the wfp
program
inside the camp they say what is
available here is enough to feed
8 000 people for an entire month and
more is coming soon
so according to them there is no
shortage of food in the camp
rations include red sorghum lentils
cooking oil
salt and food supplements for newborns
and nursing mothers
this is early days hopefully we'll get
all of these people
off the porridge as quickly as possible
the key is we get them registered
and then as soon as that's the case then
we will be giving them monthly rations
they'll be able to manage it themselves
seventy-five-year-old tariqi barely
starts eating when he abandons his meal
but a few in the camp are being creative
this woman was a government accountant
in hamera
she's six months pregnant she has
boycotted the porridge
and started a little food business of
our own
we never ate this type of food back home
we simply don't know it
we can't eat it since i had a little bit
of cash i bought some wheat flour to
make bread
and soup that suits my taste let abraham
makes bread
and soup for her family and sells what's
left over
using the money to buy more supplies
supplying a demand for food
people here want to eat while age groups
do what they can
to manage a humanitarian crisis muhammad
al-jazeera the umrakuba camp for
ethiopian refugees in sudan